reject nation
i can't tell the difference between my
waking life
and whatever that was oscar is here for
this reaction for the rest of the life
and dreams or something like that yeah
anyway we got ourselves a moon night
clip today
we got ourselves a screener in in the
email
now they sent over four but apparently
three and four aren't finished because
they won't spoil stuff so i think we're
just gonna watch only the first episode
this weekend
we're going to record our reaction
forward and we'll wait till actually
obviously the show is up to publish it
we're not going to skip ahead we're just
going to be a couple days ahead of you
guys for the actual show but we'll be on
time with you weekly right after that
leave a like leave a look in the comment
boxes
[Music]
[Applause]
cool yes
conscious
dope don't trust her
you've seen the movie devil don't trust
her
oh yeah
fine thank you
lost my contact lens
i hope you find it
electrical problems in the building
isn't it always the same isn't it
are we back on the fifth floor yes the
thief my friend claire is here
i'm visiting her
she's expecting me oh
what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
dude you know what's happening in that
uh trailer i noticed was that he can't
tell the difference between
that's right or a nightmare it's not my
good nightmare yeah that was cool it is
nice to see that marvel is staying true
to the word with keeping it truly
feeling like a supernatural horror show
i hope like this kind of vibe this tone
that they're emitting here i hope that
remains present throughout the series
because a lot of times when you know
they're teasing horror it can be like oh
yeah in the beginning they start doing
some horror stuff but once he's like oh
i know who i am i'm actually mark
spector i'm moon nut i'm a badass mofo
then it's just like mainly just action
tone like that that's kind of my concern
is that it'll it'll just switch to
action to drive only and and kind of
sacrifice some of the horror tone once
we've uh uncovered enough of the mystery
it is cool to see that marvel is truly
honing in on horror like in terms of the
mcu i feel like i've said this once or
twice before but this does seem like the
most horror it seems the most overtly
horror yeah i mean it seems like we keep
getting this sort of looming promise of
horror really really coming into the mcu
in a way that isn't just like for a
scene or two to enhance the peril or
whatever i feel like as long as we have
steven grant there's that potential
for the horror to take hold because you
know yeah obviously mark specter is
gonna be much more in control they're
gonna play bad to the bone every time he
shows up he's gonna put on sunglasses
every time i feel like this is perhaps
the true chance to really have something
where horror is a flavor throughout and
that's going to inform you know a lot of
the action in the show because too like
the indiana jones movies which they've
said are partly an inspiration for this
do have their elements of horror
throughout like most of the ruins and
temples and places he's going they do a
nice job to bridge that fun action with
horror and i feel like we're probably
going to get at least a taste of that
here and that makes me really excited
horror is probably my favorite genre and
i
keep waiting for that one that's gonna
scratch my itch as a horror fan as well
as as a fan of you know the marvel
universe and their characters and
whatnot oh yeah the physicality on
kanchi there in that moment looks really
good it looks like a definite blend of
actor and costume mixed with some cgi
specifically on the hallway shots when
he's walking down there but then the
close-up of the prosthetic of the head
looks really cool i love the details on
it it makes me wonder story-wise what
they're doing though with moon knight
because they've already shown they're
mixing up some timelines and and some
character work here like this
personality of stephen grant if you
didn't tell me with stephen grant i
would assume it is the personality of
jake lockley who was like the taxi cab
driver and stuff where
it's like steven grant in the comics is
more like a wealthy philanthropist and
such steven grant here does not look
like a dude made of money whatsoever and
there was this other trailer that i
watched over the weekend that showed him
stephen grant interacting with mark
spector and it's like in this show
they're showing that stephen graham will
probably be the primary protagonist the
personality you're hanging out with the
most at least in the beginning like i'm
wondering if they're going to do some
type of shift halfway through the season
where okay now that we've unpacked
what's going on here with this person
now we're going to shift gears where the
perspective of the show is mainly going
to be coming from mark spector himself
but in that trailer i remember mark
spector being like stephen you weren't
supposed to know any of this like he had
sort of this protective quality towards
stephen like he was trying to shield him
from all this and it seemed very
purposeful that he would do that and the
other trailers you see them go to egypt
so the presumption i had was that the
whole country possession already took
place that already happened parts of the
trailers are not making me think is the
country possession supposed to happen
later after he goes and visits the
museum and such this is a conscious
possession supposed to happen then
however i'm kind of wondering now what
if mark specter and this whole dialogue
has only been for people who know what
the hell we're talking if you don't know
what the hell moonlight is i'm just
noticing like it's all about gibberish
but i'm wondering now if like mark
specter at the point in his life where
he's at actually tried suppressing um
konchu and instead tried making like
stephen grant the dominant personality
to hide consciou for a reason and now
kanchu mark specter coinciding are going
to be reawakened that's not what they do
in the comics i know sometimes mark
spector would suppress the weaker
personality so he can be as strong as
possible now i wonder if they'll do
another flip here since i've already
been changing some stuff just from the
footage alone we'll see i mean it looks
looks cool it looks cool i mean in terms
of horror it's like nothing really like
uniquely horror about it what's exciting
is the fact that marvel's doing horror
yeah
yeah that's fair it would be nice to see
them bring their own proprietary brand
of unique horror but yeah i'll take any
horror to start this is nothing like
near we've seen a hallway gag and
someone's showing up behind you a
thousand times yeah so but it's exciting
that marvel's finally doing it that's
basically the reason to be excited about
it because it's also opened up a door
for them to do more unique horror down
the road it's like as long as that door
is open as long as they've opened that
gate to the upside down yes stranger
closes it again
yeah anyway guys moon knight we're done
yes i can't tell the difference between
when the video's over and when we do
andrew hayes andrew i don't know where
you've been i don't know why you don't
give a [ __ ] about us anymore but it
makes me feel really happy we have
someone as loyal as you who will just
stay pledged without even realizing it
not complain whatsoever just be like you
know what i don't even watch their stuff
anymore in fact i unsubscribe from their
main youtube channel but i'm here still
just because i think it's a tax
write-off to keep my card pledged on
their patreon page i don't know why we
would be and if the government comes to
calling to find out about us i'm ratting
you out but andrew thank you for being
loyal you are one of our first ever
patrons and the amount of time we've
been here you've never once seen i don't
think you've even left for a month
before i can't tell the difference
between on andrews active on on patreon
or not
but thank you for being you did
[Music]